a man says he threw a child off a
third-story balcony in the southeast
valley because he believed that she was
a demon we are learning a bit more about
what led up to that incident happened
sunday near desert inn and boulder
highway joe mohler there with what the
police report reveals joe
jerick willis allegedly threw that child
off the third story balcony at the
desert the boulder pines at his
apartment complex across the street from
where we're at here on sunday according
to the police report the day before the
incident he told the child's mother he
believed the child was full of bad
spirits
it's kind of horrible and everything and
i can't believe somebody would even do
that to a kid it's a scenario nobody
imagines happening i'm a mother of three
and i could never think of doing
something like that like many others
people living in this area off boulder
highway and d.i are shocked police say
sunday jerrick willis allegedly threw a
five-year-old girl from a third story
balcony at the boulder pines apartments
because he believed the child was a
demon after that the mother of the young
girl angela matthews reportedly shot
willis both were taken to the hospital
no normal person would do that to a
child according to the police report the
child's mother said she and jerick
believe in african spirituality and on
saturday he said he believed the girl
was full of bad spirits willis family
who all of out of state described him as
a great man and say he has a daughter of
his own and served several years in the
navy they are all shocked it makes me
think that the man is suffering from
mental illness or possibly drug
intoxication
willis's family said there was no
previous mental illness problems
psychologist dr renee solomon says the
behavior isn't normal and people should
look out for signs of abnormal behavior
this sounds like a situation where it
would have been appropriate to have him
evaluated by a psychologist
back out here live willis mother who i
spoke to earlier today says they still
have a lot of questions about what
exactly happened here at the apartment
complex as for the young girl she
remains in the hospital reporting live
on boulder highway near d.i jim mullin 8
news now